- But I have to say congratulations to you
because first of all,
I have two things I want to talk about.
One of my favorite things I saw
was you winning your award
'cause he's got,
he's not just like and EGOTSMA now.
- He has so many things.
- He's also won a Voice trophy.
So it's like VEGOTSMA.
- Yes
- He's won all the things.
So you're literally online
removing his trophies
and putting hers.
- Yes, this is one of
my favorite past times.
- But that's what we love about you.
You are such a comedian at heart.
It's so awesome.
And I love that you
changed your Twitter bio.
It now says you're currently sleeping
with the sexiest man alive.
- Yeah that's my bio baby!
(laughter)
You have to keep them on their toes.
Like I'm currently.
I don't know about next week.
Who knows what will happen.